acampando en medio de la intemperie dos
migrantes sirios se esperan ayuda a nash
y mueren llegaron hasta este punto en la
frontera entre polen y belarús después
de haber pagado casi tres mil
cuatrocientos dólares cada uno a un
coyote en turquía no son puras mentiras
te dejan en caminos donde puedes morir y
al final te dicen no somos responsables
de ti muere o lo que sea que pase
éramos muchos unas trece personas pero
nos separamos algunos murieron en el
camino algunos regresaron no tenemos
noticias de otros
a nash y yo nos quedamos solos no
tenemos ropa perdí mi pasaporte
se suponía que el viaje terminaría en un
lugar seguro en polonia pero algunos
cruces fueron cerrados los dos sirios
fueron abandonados muchos de los
migrantes han sido repatriados pero
otros siguen esperando a alcanzar
territorio de la unión europea no hay
marcha atrás cuando familias enteras
vendieron todo en sus países de origen
cada vez más personas se están dando
cuenta de que han caído en una trampa y
que lo que se les prometió es una
mentira porque antes les dijeron que el
camino hacia la unión europea a través
de belarús era recto animaron a familias
enteras a vivir así como a personas
enfermas la crisis en la frontera entre
belarús y polonia se ha prolongado desde
hace cinco meses la unión europea acusa
al presidente de belarús de provocar la
crisis
polonia acusa a rusia de estar detrás de
lo que sucede mientras que belarús dice
que el bloque europeo no hace nada y
mientras aumenta este intercambio de
culpas una es controlable red de tráfico
de personas se sigue lucrando de los
migrantes a quienes han llegado a cobrar
hasta siete mil dólares por persona
según datos de la policía de polonia
cerca de 314 contrabandistas de países
como alemania suecia ucrania y georgia
han sido detenidos en el país desde
agosto